it was the height of the depression and
America was in desperate need of a hero
they found it in the most unlikely of
places a battler who looked about as
beat up as the nation itself for a
racehorse he didn't have much going for
him his legs were sooo short his neck
was too thick and he had a swaying
forelegs that jutted out wildly worst of
all he had a mind of his own when he
felt like running it ran and when he
didn't he simply wouldn't it's hard to
believe that this horse a horse that
lost his first 17 starts would become a
legend the greatest race horse in
history in this episode of biographic
smart-looking a person but indeed were
looking at the amazing story of
Seabiscuit the horse the brought in
nation together Seabiscuit was born or
more accurately fold on May 23rd 1933 in
Lexington Kentucky he was the son of a
nasty temper Drogo named hardtack and a
gentleman named swag on Seabiscuit
father had great speed no doubt owing to
his pedigree his father Manawa was
considered by most experts at the time
to be the greatest racehorse whoever was
produced although his grandson would
certainly go on to challenge that claim
the problem with hardtack was that he
was uncontrollable even Hall of Fame
trainer sonny jim Fitzsimmons couldn't
tame him Seabiscuit smother was the
complete opposite of hardtack she was a
calm gentle horse with thick knees and
short legs swing on wasn't very fast
though so she never raced the Colt that
she sired didn't look very promising his
legs were study his knees were thick and
he looked sort of funny when he ran even
Seabiscuit's color was against him he
was a solid muddy bay with no
distinguishing white stripe or star on
his face so these horses they were all
loans by Ogden Mills Secretary of the US
Treasury miss one is his sister mrs. HC
Phipps they're racing staple was one of
the finest in America with no expense
being spared in the care and training of
the horses however mrs. Phipps insisted
that only horses that would bring honor
to the stable would be capped the reason
that hard tack and swing on work still
around was that they both had
very strong pedigrees it was hoped that
their offspring would have amazing speed
during his first year Seabiscuit along
with his mother was put into a 50 acre
pasture with none other thoroughbred
mares and then you born false so in
every group of cults there are usually
two that stand out one is the hero the
better-looking more graceful and faster
one and the other is the outcast an
awkward runty looking little fellow who
looked as if he slipped in when no one
was watching in this group the hero is
Granville then to the outcasts
Seabiscuit but something in Seabiscuit
stood out to keen observers several
times a day the Colts would race up and
down the paddock with Seabiscuit always
at the rear yet the gangly Colt was
never discouraged the father he was left
behind the harder he drove himself and
the longer the race the nearer he came
catching up with his big head and short
spindly legs
Seabiscuit spent more energy than other
Colts running as a result of this he had
a large wrap time from the other Colts
and even developed stronger and tougher
leg muscles and by late that fall he was
no longer running at the back of the
pack emerging as a yearling on January
the 1st 1934 Seabiscuit looked more like
a ragged range pony than a thoroughbred
he failed to shed his winter coat and
his legs and back were a few inches
shorter than average in fact he was such
an ugly duckling the when mrs. fibs came
in April to inspect her horses
Seabiscuit was hidden away in an
outlying barn by now though Seabiscuit
had found his running legs he was
challenging Granville for the lead he
may not have had at the physical
attributes of the other horses but he
was full of stamina and determination so
by mid-summer these rivals they were
absolutely racing neck-and-neck and it
was then Seabiscuit developed a habit
that would be the trademark that it
carry for the rest of his life
whatever they were vying for the lead he
would snorted Granville there's an
attempt to bully him and throw
[Music]
in June of 1934 Granville and Seabiscuit
they were ships to sunny Jim Fitzsimmons
recognized as perhaps the finest trainer
in the country Fitzsimmons had developed
a hatred for sea biscuits father
hardtack after years of being unable to
break him his vicious habits he had also
given up on swing on finding her too
slow and lazy this did not bode well for
Seabiscuit who Fitzsimmons looked upon
as a curse from the very beginning he
put the majority of his energy into
training Granville while forcing
Seabiscuit to conform Seabiscuit
meanwhile was determined not to comply
he simply refused to go fast finally an
exasperated Fitzsimmons gave his jockey
a wooden stake and told him hit
Seabiscuit just as many times as he can
in a quarter-mile they're running
against Faust the fastest sprinter among
the group in trying to escape these
severe beating Seabiscuit exploded
around the track leaving Faust far in
his wake he ran the quarter mile in 22
seconds and 2/5 and if you don't know
this is an incredibly good time it
amazed Fitzsimmons but it also confirmed
in his mind
Seabiscuit would only show his potential
under severe punishment when on January
31st 1935 the horses under Fitzsimmons
became two-year-olds Seabiscuit it was
tossed aside it was put to work say hack
racer
January the 19th he was entered into a
short race losing by four and a half
lengths during 1935 he ran a total of 35
races losing the first 17 which was not
exactly a brilliant start it was only
when his jockey stopped beating him and
let him run his own race that he showed
real promise he won five races setting
three track records in the process still
that Simmons he was desperate to get rid
of him convinced to that Seabiscuit was
an inconsistent no hope that on August
the 3rd 1936 Fitzsimmons entered
Seabiscuit in the $6,000 claiming stakes
at Saratoga fortunately for him this
just happened to be one of those days
when Seabiscuit decided to turn it on he
won by six full lengths up in the stands
an old-time veteran cowboy and veteran
trainer named Tom Smith saw heart and
courage in Seabiscuit he decided have
a week later Seabiscuit he was purchased
by Charles Howard for $8,000 and hand it
over to Tom Smith for training the horse
finally had a trainer who both respected
him and saw his limitless potential
Seabiscuit was subjected to an intense
conditioning campaign the horses that no
one wanted suddenly was pampered and
groomed with a focus on foot care in
order to recover from the grueling
schedule he had been forced to endure
under Fitzsimmons as a result of the
care and attention that was lavished
upon him Seabiscuit began performing
more consistently on the practice track
he became gentler and seemed to develop
the competitive spirit he also developed
a huge appetite eating anything that was
put before him to keep his weight down
grooms were instructed to muzzle him at
night in order to prevent him from
eating his straw bedding a combination
of patience kindness and skillful
training of Tom Smith managed to
transform Seabiscuit's courage and
intelligence into raw unbridled speed
all that was needed now is to match
Seabiscuit with the right jockey
Smith found him in the form of Jack red
Pollard a feisty 27 year old Canadian
who'd been roaming around the West
Riding and boxing for over a decade
his other thoroughbreds was as deep as
Tom Smith's yes although he was one of
the better jockeys on the bush circuit
had only won three state races in his
life when red first entered Seabiscuit
stalled the horse was busy munching on
straw Seabiscuit looked up gave a snort
and then ambled over to polit and rubbed
his muzzle against Reds shoulder and
well with that one of history's greatest
partnerships was born satisfied he was
ready Howard entered Seabiscuit into a
series of races in Detroit in two races
the Detroit governor's handicapped and
the Scarsdale handicap he came a home
first
netting twelve thousand nine hundred
dollars in prize money for his owner
over the next two months the winnings
accrued to a remarkable forty thousand
dollars a delight at Howard gave him a
two-month vacation in November 1936
Seabiscuit he was sent by rail to
California to compete in his last two
races as a three-year-old the first it
was the baybridge handicap despite
starting badly read and Seabiscuit soon
found their stride and they won by five
lengths in their last race of the year
for Wells Fair handicap they led from
the start cruising to an easy victory by
the beginning of 1937 Seabiscuit was
beginning to
developer reputation as a pup incoming
champion the focus in the early part of
the year was watches Santa Anita Cup the
biggest race on the west coast
Seabiscuit started the year well winning
a warm-up race in Santa Anita in January
then in the san antonio handicap he was
bumped at the start and pushed white
finishing a disappointing fifth and now
well it was time for the big one
the 125 thousand dollar Santa Anita Cup
coming down the home straight Seabiscuit
was half a length ahead of Rosemont the
horse which would won the week before at
San Antonio but red Pollard who was
blind in his right eye didn't know that
Rosamond's was closing in and failed to
Seabiscuit into the next year
Rosemont won by a nose this
disappointment though it was followed by
three easy wins establishing Seabiscuit
reputation on the west coast as the
breakout thoroughbred of the year by
this time Charles Howard who is making
some pretty great money off this
investment but he wanted more he was
determined that Seabiscuit to be
recognized as the greatest racehorse in
the entire United States that meant
breaking in to the far more prestigious
East Coast circuit so between June the
26th and August the 7th he entered
Seabiscuit into five East Coast races
and he won every single one of them he
finished 1937 with a record 11 wins out
of 15 races and was the biggest money
earner in the country
he was also now the most famous horse in
America with the press having a field
day with his underdog story the nation's
most prestigious neck wine award however
did not go to Seabiscuit that year the
winner of the American Horse of the Year
award was the darling of the East Coast
set or admiral who had just won the
coveted Triple Crown
[Music]
interestingly war Admiral and
Seabiscuit's they're actually blood
relatives saver the son and grandson of
one of the greatest thoroughbreds in
history Man O'War Seabiscuit's father
hardtack was war Admirals brother in
1937 war admiral won every race he
started including the Triple Crown this
prestigious honor is bestowed upon
thoroughbreds that win three major races
in succession the Kentucky Derby
Preakness Stakes and Belmont Stakes but
war admirals victory at Belmont when it
was bittersweet an injury prevented him
from racing again for several months or
admiral was a natural competitor the
lively activity of race day seemed to
fill him with nervous excitement he was
so competitive it was difficult for
handlers to hold him back when the
saddling bell rang his temperament was
fiery and skittish just like his brother
heart attack but this personality that
usually worked his advantage
he never willingly walked into the gates
and once the starters got him in he
would act up causing delays and false
starts at the beginning of 1938 war
admiral was the best horse in the east
and Seabiscuit was the best horse in the
West race fans were anxious for the two
champions to meet that chance Howard
knew that despite the public's
fascination with his unlikely star if
Seabiscuit were to be taken seriously as
a challenge to war Admiral he would have
to establish his own reputation in the
East Howard was a master promoter and
capitalized on establishing racing
rivalry between the East Coast and the
west coast
he was determined to prove that horse
coming out of California could be the
equal of anything that ran in the east
and it was at this point that he began
issuing public challengers to Sam riddle
the owner of War Admiral riddle ignored
him considering it demeaning for his
champion thoroughbreds to meet a Western
horse but after months of incessant
media chiding well he finally agreed
[Music]
the question of who is the fastest horse
in the United States would be decided by
way of a race to be held at the Pimlico
racetrack in Baltimore Maryland this
would take place on November the 1st
1938 the distance was to be 1 and 16th
miles
Rizal insisted however that the race
begin with no gate or a walk-up start in
order to avoid war Admirals
temperamental behavior in the gate
howard agreed to start the race with a
starting Bell but he also had a
condition the track had to be fast or
dry Seabiscuit he did not run well in
mutt if the track was too wet because of
rain the race it would be called off
then things while they started to go
wrong in the Seabiscuit camp
red Pollard fractured his leg while
working with another horse and he was
unable to race Paula's good friends and
fellow top jockey George the Iseman wolf
would ride Seabiscuit instead up until
that time every match race in history
had been won by the horse that was in
the lead from the start
throughout all of his races in 1937 War
Admiral had never let another horse in
front of him yet Seabiscuit he was a
come-from-behind winner war admirals
trainer George Conway and jockey Charlie
Curtsinger were confidence that their
horse was faster than Seabiscuit this
meant they concentrated on building War
Admiral stamina to endure the mile long
distance in while Tom Smith was
concentrating on the start of the race
he put together a starting Bell that
sounded like the starting Bell at
Pimlico when he rang the bell Wolfe
cracked the whip on Seabiscuit's
backside this condition Seabiscuit to
run at top speed immediately the race of
the century it was a worldwide sensation
the racetrack was so crowded that 10,000
people crowded outside the gates sitting
in trees and standing on car roofs to
try to see the race across the United
States 40 million people tuned their
radios in many of them didn't care about
horse racing previously but now they
were keen to hear history being made
most of them while they were rooting for
Seabiscuit
Charlie Curtsinger on war admiral wore
black and yellow silks and rode the rail
while george wolf with red and white
silks sitting astride Seabiscuit took
the outside
War Admiral prepared for the race the
way he always did rearing up and
tormenting his handlers meanwhile
Seabiscuit calmly headed for the post
the flag was raised and the horses lined
up but just as the starter was about to
ring the bell will pull
Seabiscuit back it was a tactic to make
War Admiral nervous when they lined up a
second iron Curtsinger pulled his horse
back on the third try both horses lined
up at exactly the same moment the
starter bell rang and they were off the
two thoroughbreds pounded down the track
neck-and-neck it was commonly believed
that War Admiral would take the early
lead so the crowd were astonished when
Wolfe cracked the whip and Seabiscuit
edged in front around the first turn
Seabiscuit was still in the lead Wolfe
veered left and took the rail from
Curtsinger then he slowed Seabiscuit
right down in front of War Admiral in
order to conserve energy
Curtsinger now either had to slow down
himself or pass Wolfe War Admiral drew
closer to Seabiscuit but was still ahead
by a length and a half
going into the backstretch the distance
widened by two lengths then Curtsinger
cracked the whip and in just a few
strides war admiral was even with
Seabiscuit the crowd by this point they
were going absolutely wild horses
charged down the straight neck-and-neck
then where Admiral took the lead but
only for a moment - Seabiscuit sped up
he was once again in front turning into
the stretch it was anybody's race they
rounded the far turn and were headed for
home they were a couple shoulder to
shoulder head to head I tie around the
turn as they headed for home wolf cracks
the whip asking Seabiscuit for
everything he had he loosened the reins
and the horse answered dropping his chin
his ears pinned back and he raced
towards the finish line the crowd they
were astounded to see Seabiscuit break
away by one then two then three lengths
in the end it was no contest Seabiscuit
was the winner by 4 lengths leaving War
Admiral in his dust a Seabiscuit slowed
to a gallop thousands of fans burst
through the infield chasing their
underdog hero in the winner's circle
Seabiscuit was donned with a blanket of
yellow flowers or Admirals barn met
their defeated champion and slept away
almost unnoticed Seabiscuit was now not
only the National racing champion but
the fastest and most famous horse in the
world he easily won horse of the year in
however the dreyfus Seabiscuit it was
short-lived in the next race he ruptured
a ligament in his leg he spent most of
1939 heeling at the Howard ranch in
California the comeback for both
Seabiscuit and jockey red Pollard still
recovering from his own leg injury was
to be the 1948 Santa Anita
de Kamp during the race Seabiscuit got
caught in a pocket which red tried
desperately to get out of finally
finding his gaffe he yells now pops
Seabiscuit broke through took the lead
and never looks back
[Applause]
[Music]
following the Santa round a victory
Seabiscuit retired with a record of 33
victories from 89 races here dans
Charles Howard four hundred and
thirty-eight thousand dollars an
American record at the time
Seabiscuit died suddenly of a heart
attack on labor 17 in 1947
three years later Charles Howard's horse
nor won the 1950s Center Anita Handicap
when a reporter suggested that perhaps
it found another Seabiscuit
he answered sir there will never be
another Seabiscuit so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday also do
check out some of our other videos over
there on the right and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]